Wow Amer is here Moe is gonna be at
Caroline's on Broadway tonight through
Saturday then he's heading to Boston
then DC go to Moe americ-aa Memo am er
calm it's weird you tore my knee toward
Dave and when you're torn with a comic
who's your pal great gigs it's it's then
you gotta go out and headline gigs I've
had that switch where it's like [ __ ]
it's so much more fun like it's better
money when you're doing it yourself but
when you're touring with a huge comedian
it's so much more fun because you just
kind of walk in you have to worry about
anything there's no ticket pressure on
you there's if there could be any such
thing as ticket pressure on Chappelle's
Show yeah I guess we'll do 11 Radio City
I guess this time hey can we add eight
shows okay we could do that and then you
go on the road and they're like all
right look they show us a little light
warning
[Laughter]
how did you end up on tour with
Chappelle well we had a tour call Allah
made me funny like back in the day we
became friends in 2007 oh he was on that
to her no he just popped into our show
and cause he was just like really he was
really just really pleased to see
somebody like outside of the business we
were touring all over the world like we
were selling out theaters all over the
place and he was like how are you guys
doing this outside of it like this is
crazy I said it was really amazing in
2007 I mean we were touring globally
doing South Africa where people weren't
going you know and doing theatres after
her and Cape they're doing Cape down on
the Durban - whatever - throughout
Europe and the Apollo and London so it
was just like it was the thing that he
had a lot of respect for us for doing
such an indie tour and then we became
friends and then in 2012 it just
happened to be in San Francisco at the
same time he was he was in Oakland I was
performing in the bay and I saw that he
was there I was
and we went by and said hello and he was
like hey you want to open tomorrow I was
like beginning of his comeback in 2012
when I was like oh yeah and then he was
like yeah I'm gonna come out tomorrow I
never had advance notice for a ting
Chappelle shows ever we've done over a
thousand shows together he introduced me
for my special on Netflix and he I've
never I've never had like more than a
week I think what I enjoy about watching
Dave is not necessarily seeing him in
those venues where he's you know super
tight and ready I think the best
scenarios where I've seen him in where
he's just doing you know three hours and
just thinking on stage yeah
like probably thirty minutes of that
three hours is him thinking and I'm
comfortable he's good talker James a
great talk like so it so even if it's
not a laugh if he's just speculating on
something or working through it so what
an interesting mind like what does the
right guy and what a natural soothing
voice
he's just easy to listen to it's a gift
to have that you some people having some
dog he's very very easy to listen to
he's just talking something through yeah
I remember the night that Prince died
Brewer in San Francisco together and of
course that was devastating and he you
know he had a show already booked it
started the show started at 1:00 a.m.
which is pretty [ __ ] ridiculous
it was at the chapel in Oakland why so
late and he just I think there was a
shows before then he couldn't get I
think so I don't know why sometimes he
just does those midnight [ __ ] cuz
he's Dave Chappelle and it's our show
literally whatever time you want it
likes going on lazy that's true comment
by the time he got on it was like 130
140 you know and he goes on and and we
didn't get out of it so like 7:00 in the
morning like only do people left really
yeah nobody leaves and he was just out
there all night
working through prints and everything
yeah he had a band too so he would just
play with the band a little bit and go
back and forth and you know he just
it was just masterful and to see
somebody do that and nobody like two
people left and I think just because
they probably had to go to work not even
I said I have to go home and sleep
before it like
literally have to leave from here and go
to work now something like that he's
done that so many times